it is our responsibility to remember it
there is Holocaust denial which is a
very sad feature of our society and we
have a responsibility to the victims and
to the survivors to guarantee that it
will be remembered there is of course
also time and the survivors are getting
old it's so inevitably presumably will
to a certain extent retreat for a modern
conscience absolutely and you know I've
just come from the Holocaust Memorial
Day National ceremony very moving today
and for me the central aspect of it was
the cry that the survivors are issuing
to us please guarantee that this will
never be forgotten because every year
these ceremonies there are few of them
and to put it at its simplest what is
the unique significance of the Holocaust
why should we never forget it the
Holocaust was a europe-wide attempt in
order to annihilate the people the sheer
extent of it if you visit the birkin are
extermination camp and you see hut after
hut after hut if you go to forest
throughout Europe if you see the extent
to which thousands upon thousands of
people were collaborators joining in
this effort led by national governments
in order to exterminator people together
with others this is something
extraordinary and the Prince of Wales in
his speech he mentioned things that have
happened in Africa and elsewhere around
the world but is there still something
is it the scale of it is the fact that
it was happening what was regarded as
the center of civilization that makes it
so sure I think you've actually
highlighted what is special about the
Holocaust but of course there is so much
that we can learn from the Holocaust in
order to apply within our society I
think it's important for us to engage in
education in order that through
awareness of what transpired all those
years ago we'll be able to be armed to
prevent it ever recurring do you think
that the reaction the discovery of the
Holocaust has meant that anti-semitism
is now much weaker force than it was
in the last century we're not trying to
compete with others in order always to
be at the top of the list unfortunately
recent events have shown that
anti-semitism is now on an increase in
the world and also statistics show in
the UK as well but you know everybody
today is of the frontline events in
Paris within a few days showed us how
today everybody is genuinely concerned
why do you think it is that people
revisit this issue is it because of
Israel you know anti-semitism has
existed from the very time that the
Jewish people existed there is general
racism and xenophobia and there is a
particular hatred it's called the
longest hatred of the Jew so the
existence of the State of Israel didn't
create anti-semitism sometimes not
always but sometimes anti-zionism
creates an environment within which
anti-semitism can thrive and many people
would say that the behavior of the State
of Israel unfortunately its attitude
towards the Palestinians what's happened
there has poured fuel on a you know the
anti-semitism to a certain extent
anti-semitism is a phenomenon that has
existed for many many years and actually
as I see it a lot of what is happening
in the Middle East comes as a result of
anti-semitism and is not provoking
anti-semitism you don't think that the
policies are present Israeli government
is to a certain extent fuels anti Center
well you know in Israel itself which is
a very robust democracy who are ongoing
debate regarding odyssey's of the State
of Israel
turtleman's an occupying land that the
United Nations said it shouldn't be
occupying yes so sure enough during the
summer Israel experienced a barrage of
missiles there was an existential threat
to the Jewish people that Israel
defended herself now and there are
perceptions yes and sometimes
perceptions as you say do lend
themselves towards images and towards
impressions but certainly some of the
hatred which is aimed towards Israel is
a result
intimate or not the other way around and
as far just finally as far as during
this country Jewish people living in
this country we heard people in France
saying they didn't feel safe should the
Jewish community feel safe
do you feel as proud
country knowing that the fight against
anti-semitism is not one which is being
left to the Jewish people to fight it's
been fought from the government down we
have so many good friends so many allies
and as I said earlier we're actually all
in this together thank you very much
thank you